هذه المره ناتي الى الجانب المظلم في كره
القدم للاسف ثمانيه ساعات عنصريه واجهها
اللاعب البرازيلي شاب فينيسيوس جونيور في
الموسم الحالي فقط ثمانيه تاره طبعا
ينتقدوا رقصه بعد تسجيل الاهداف او يهتفون
بموته حتى خلال المباراه اخرها الهتافات
العنصريه التي تعرض لها خلال اللقاء فريق
ريال مدريد امام فالنسيا في الدوري
الاسباني وهزت المشهد الرياضي العالمي
ريال مدريد اصدر بيانا يعلن فيه تقدمه
بشكوى الى مكتب المدعي العام
ضد الك
راهيه الواقعه بينما تعاهدت رابطه لا ليغا
ايضا بالتحقيق فيما حدث وحرص الكثير من
اللاعبين وانديه الدوريات الكبرى على دعم
اللاعب صدى الواقعات طبعا وصل الى الولاده
سيلفا الرئيس البرازيلي الذي طالب باتخاذ
اجراءات حقيقيه لمنع الفاشيه كما اسماها
من الهيمنه على كره القدم كما قال طبعا
احنا بدنا نعرف المزيد من التفاصيل
المشاهدين عن هذه الواقعه لذا سنذهب لعلاء
اتفضلي يا علاء تفضل
بالفعل في الدقيقه الثالثه والسبعين من
مباراه ريال مدريد التي خاضها الاحد امام
فالنسيا في الجوله 35 من الدوري الاسباني
اشتبك فينيسيوس جونيور لاعب المرينجي مع
جماهير الخصم التي ضلت تهتف ضده طوال
المباراه الفوضى اوقفت اللعب نحو عشر
دقائق ولم يستانف اللعب حتى طالبت مكبرات
الصوت في ملعب مستايا بوقف هتافات
الكراهيه ما زاد الطين بالله طرد فينيسيوس
في الدقائق الاخيره من المباراه بعد تورطه
في شجار مع لاعب فالنسيا هوغودورو بينما
لم يطرد الحكم اللاعب الاسباني وهو ما
وصفه معلقون بان الفار عنصري ايضا
فينيسيوس نشر بيانا على تويتر يقول فيه
البطوله التي كانت في احدى الايام ملكا
لرونالدو وميسي تنتمي اليوم للعنصريين كما
وصف الطرد الذي تحصل عليه في نهايه
المباراه
بالهديه التي فاز بها ممارسوه العنصريه
[موسيقى]
في الاستوديو ينضم الينا الصحفي الرياضي
محمد حامد محمد صباح الخير اهلا وسهلا
صباح الخير يا
محمد خليني اسالك بانهم يعني فقره القدم
في ملاعب كره القدم عادي انه اللاعب يستفز
الجمهور الجمهور يستفز اللاعب حتى يجعل في
حاله حاله عدم التركيز في المباراه لكن
اليوم ما حدث مع فينيسيوس ليست المره
الاولى وصارت وليست من نادي واحد فقط من
اكثر من نادي او مشجعي نادي تعرضوا لي
فينيسيوس بهذه العباره عادل
انا حزين جدا لان اتابع كره عالميه يعني
من سنوات طويله وخلينا نقول برضو مش
عايزين نمارس احنا العنصريه على غيرنا
الظاهره غربيه بامتياز للاسف يعني انا
مثلا لا اراها في الملاعب العربيه وربما
حتى في قارات واماكن اخرى خليني يعني اقول
بهذه الصوره تقصد انها تحدث بهذه تحدث
تحدث بكل تاكيد بس الوتيره اعلى في
ايطاليا واسبانيا سؤال اخر لماذا لا نجدها
بهذه الوتيره في انجلترا هناك حزب هناك
يقولون دائما في انجلترا
انجلترا يتعلق بالملكه الى هذا الحد يعني
يحافظه على بطولتهم
هيك ممكن تسمع بعض الهتافات العنصريه في
ملاعب البريطانيه
ربما حتى خليني بس في جزئيه مهمه جدا بلاش
ناخد فكره فينيسيوس او القضيه من فكره
العنصريه اللي هي فكره مهينه للانسانيه
كلها ونختصرها في فكره ان هذا اللاعب
مستفز لا يجب علينا ان نقع في هذا الخطا
هو مستفز بالمناسبه مشروع بالمناسبه تسع
وقائع عنصريه في ملاعب اسبانيا هذا الموسم
8 منها لفينيسيوس طب ليه هو اللي بيستفز
الجمهور مثلا الولد هو شاب صغير 22 سنه
مهاري جدا امهر لاعب في العالم بعد ميسي
حاليا وسيكون من افضل لاعبين في العالم
ثانيا مستفز في يعني نقول عنه استفزاز
كروي يتعمد خليني اقول لك اهانه الخصم
اثناء لعب الكره مش اهانه لفظيه او اهانه
انه بطريقه مهينه كذا
يشتبك مع الجمهور يرد على كل اساءه في
الملعب كره القدم لا تخلو من اساءه
ومناوشات داخل
[موسيقى]
ثقافه انا في رايي في رايي احنا لن نبحث
لن نبحث عن الضمير ولن نبحث عن الحب ولا
نبحث عن الكراهيه اذا عايزين نحل مشكله
فورا نحلها بالقانون نيلسون مانديلا يا
عادل علموهم الحب فهو اسهل من ان تعلموهم
الكراهيه لا يوجد لا يوجد شخص لا يوجد
مولود في هذا العالم يتجه الى كراهيه
الاخر لمجرد
هل سيغادر فينيسيوس ويدفع يدفع على الخروج
من الملاعب الاسبانيه لان اصبحت مساله
شخصيه وليست فقط
مساله عنصريه ليش ما تحدث مع غيره من
اللاعبين السمر يعني احد اللاعبين
باشبيليا يعتقد قال انه انا ما ابي ابني
يشوف حركاته
احد الحلول البسيطه جدا ولكنها مستحيله
لانها لن تحدث انا دائما اقول وبعض الاراء
الغربيه تقول العنصريه ليست فعل العنصريه
هي في رد الفعل يعني حينما يتعمد شخص
لمجرد ان لون بشرتي مختلفه في في حال كان
عندي رد فعل غاضب غاضب فانا مكنته من
الوصول لهدفه ما يتعلق بفينيسيوس اذا رحل
لاي نادي في العالم سوف تلاحقه نفس
الحكافات اذا لم تتغير شخصيته واذا لم يكن
اكثر هدوءا في الملعب وريال مدريد يدافع
عنه
استاذ
كان معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات